la rapporteur notre commission d'enquête
sur la pénurie de médicaments et les
choix de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française poursuit ses travaux en
recevant aujourd'hui Monsieur Laurent
ben David président de la Chambre
syndical de la répartition
pharmaceutique
accompagnée de Monsieur Emmanuel
Deschain délégué général qui pour la
chambre syndicale de la répartition
pharmaceutique comme son nom l'indique
et l'organisation professionnelle
patronale des entreprises de la
répartition pharmaceutique votre rôle
est de représenter ces maillons
incontournables de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement en médicament que
sont les grossistes répartiteurs
interfaces essentielles entre d'une part
les laboratoires et d'autre part les
plus de
21000 officines françaises votre
participation à la prévention et à la
gestion des ruptures de médicaments
étant consacrée par la loi à l'article
l5124-17-2 du code de la santé publique
il était naturel essentiel que nous vous
entendions surtout il nous semble
important de tenter d'y voir clair dans
le circuit de distribution du médicament
qui en France en tout cas ne brille pas
forcément par sa simplicité c'est au
moins ce qui nous est apparu à la
lumière de l'audition que nous avons
menée le 12 avril dernier lorsque nous
avons reçu la Fédération Française de la
distribution exotique et la fédération
nationale est dépositaire
pharmaceutiques lock santé du site de
production à la pharmacie les flux de
médicaments sont en effet gérés selon
diverses modalités dans notre pays les
grossistes répartiteurs que vous
représentez sont des établissements
pharmaceutiques qui ont des obligations
de services publics il doit desservir en
continu toutes les offices de leur
territoire de répartition de manière à
couvrir les besoins des patients en
France livrez tout médicament de leur
stock dans les 24 heures et détenir en
permanence 90% des présentations de
spécialités pharmaceutiques
commercialisées en France ainsi qu'un
stock représentant deux semaines de
consommation habituelles sur leur zone
de chalandise déclarée laquelle est
soumise par ailleurs à autorisation du
directeur général de la direction
générale de la NSL ils doivent aussi
participer à un système d'astreinte
inter-entreprise le samedi après 14
heures le dimanche et les jours fériés
deuxième type d'acteurs les dépositaires
ils ne sont pas propriétaires des
médicaments dont ils assurent la
distribution en tant que prestataire de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ils agissent
pour le compte d'un donneur d'Orne dont
ils sont les sous-traitants leur mode de
rémunération donc leur équilibre
économique diffère à cet égard de celui
des grossistes répartiteurs qui comme
leur nom l'indique sont chargés de
garantir une répartition équitable des
produits de santé sur le territoire et
dont le modèle repose sur une marge
réglementée fixée par les pouvoirs
publics vous nous direz si ce modèle de
rémunération reste viable dans le Figaro
du 11 avril dernier il était décrit
comme Abou de souffle
troisième possibilité enfin certains
laboratoires vont leur produire
directement aux officines notamment mais
pas seulement lorsqu'il s'agit de
médicaments onéreux ou quand la
population concernée est faible la
difficulté provient à la fois de cette
coexistence de différents types de flux
auxquels s'attachent des normes
différentes et du non-respect de leurs
obligations de service public par
certains grossissent des short liners
phénomène dont les contours nous
apparaissent encore floues même à
l'issue de d'un certain nombre
d'auditions il s'agit donc avec vous de
tirer au clair l'éventuelle
responsabilité des acteurs de la
distribution pharmaceutique dans
l'aggravation chronique des ruptures et
de réfléchir à la façon dont les
intermédiaires logistiques que vous êtes
pourrait contribuer à résoudre enfin ces
difficultés d'approvisionnement qui ne
font que croître en maillant le
territoire le plus équitablement
possible et on fluidifiant la relation
entre l'offre et la demande de
médicaments puisque nous avons aussi à
maintes reprises constatée que la notion
de pénurie pouvait être extrêmement
différent d'un territoire à l'autre
voire d'une pharmacie à l'autre sur un
même territoire je vais donc vous céder
la parole pour un bref propos
introductif j'insiste sur le Bref qui
vous donnera l'occasion de nous éclairer
très concrètement sur l'exercice de
votre profession et de nous présenter
vos analyses et préconisations
concernant la prévention et la gestion
des pénuries de médicaments
puis madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur
heureux de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fait
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et pas cible
des peines prévues aux articles 434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je vous
invite chacun votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur ben David
monsieur Deschamps
je vous remercie et vous laisse donc la
parole pour le propos liminaire
madame la présidente madame
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
reporters tout d'abord merci de nous
accueillir dans le cadre de cette
commission je pense qu'il est important
que les entreprises que nous
représentons dans le cadre de la Chambre
syndicale de la répartition de
pharmaceutique puisse vous exposer au
travers de mes propos des propos
d'emmanuels notre vision par rapport à
la distribution de la spécialité
spécialité remboursée ou médicament sur
le marché français tout d'abord nous
tenons à rappeler un point qui est je
crois vous l'avez madame la Présidente
bien soulignée durant votre propos qui
est le fait que la logistique est un
métier complexe mais que les grossistes
répartiteurs dans l'ensemble sont
capables de démontrer un service de
qualité en effet les grossistes
répartiteurs sont un maillon essentiel
et indispensable dans la chaîne de
distribution du médicament en effet nous
sommes le seul acteur logistique capable
de livrer quotidiennement plusieurs fois
par jour dans des conditions optimales
de respect de qualité distribution au
21000 pharmacies du pays avec 175
établissements répartis sur tout le
territoire
les répartiteurs sont un logisticien de
ce qu'on appelle le dernier kilomètre
nous l'ensemble de la profession
effectue chaque année 180 millions de
kilomètres par an pour livrer l'ensemble
des 21000 pharmacies je vous donne ce
chiffre là c'est pour vous donner un
petit peu l'étendue du service qui est
donné à l'ensemble des pharmacies des
pharmacies françaises bien évidemment
nous livrons l'ensemble des 21000
pharmacies y compris celles dans des
territoires les plus reculés et dans un
dans une période où nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles à notre
capacité à couvrir l'ensemble du
territoire pour apporter la santé à
l'ensemble de nos cositoyens c'est un
point qui nous semble indispensable dans
le cadre de notre mission d'acteurs de
santé publique pour vous donner quelques
chiffres aujourd'hui 71%
des volumes de médicaments vendus en
France et 80% de la valeur du marché du
médicament en France traverse passe au
travers
des grossistes répartiteurs en effet
comme vous l'avez expliqué madame la
Présidente il y a une partie de la
distribution du médicament en France qui
se fait au travers des grossistes
répartiteurs et une autre partie qui
passe en direct soit depuis
l'élaboratoires directement ou au
travers de dépositaire qui je crois ou
des shortliners que vous avez auditionné
auparavant
nous assurons une qualité de service
élevée puisque nous sommes capables
d'assurer un taux de service de
99,5%. lorsque les stocks sont
disponibles dans nos établissements
pharmaceutiques qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire 99,5 % c'est-à-dire que quand le
stock
on a en aval et 10 est disponible chez
les grossistes répartiteurs nous sommes
capables de le servir à
99,5%. donc tout un tas de questions se
posent sur la capacité à
s'approvisionner sur le sourcing et la
capacité à livrer nos établissements
pharmaceutiques afin de permettre de
faire en sorte que le dernier kilomètre
soit parcouru pour arriver jusqu'au
pharmacie et donc automatiquement nos
concitoyens
le phénomène touche aujourd'hui
des médicaments d'usage courant sachez
juste que cette situation de pénurie
c'est quelque chose avec sur lequel
vivons et nous surfants depuis un
certain nombre d'années la seule
différence qu'il y a et vous avez dû le
lire dans l'article du Figaro du 11
avril puisque j'avais été
interviewé par le journaliste c'est que
ça touche de plus en plus de médicaments
d'usage courant phénomène qui n'était
pas habituels dans les années passées et
donc en effet se retrouve sur la place
publique des médicaments connus de nos
concitoyens
tels que le doliprane tel que des
corticoïdes tels que
l'amoxicilline qui est automatiquement
mette en lumière en particulier ce
phénomène de pénurie
deuxième point sur lequel nous
souhaitions échanger avec vous c'est une
pratique de l'industrie qui s'appelle la
pratique des quotas le marché a beaucoup
évolué ces dernières années avec de plus
en plus de contingentements
cela un impact sur les habitudes de
consommation des pharmacies avec par
exemple plus de commandes en début de
mois puisque il y a des risques de
contingentement donc automatiquement les
pharmaciens sur certains médicaments où
il y a des risques de tension anticipent
l'approvisionnement de ces médicaments
cette pratique des quotas consiste de la
part des laboratoires pharmaceutiques à
définir un quota de produits pour chaque
marché national et attribuer ces
quantités au grossiste répartiteurs en
fonction de leur part de marché c'est à
dire que un laboratoire va décider que
sur un produit le marché français est
capable d'absorber un volume X et
ensuite réparti en fonction des parts de
marché de chacun des grossistes
répartiteurs le quota lui correspondant
c'est Quentin doivent être distingués de
se pratiquer par les grossistes
répartiteurs à la demande de la NSM dans
le cadre de la gestion des tensions de
rupture et qui vise à assurer une
distribution plus équitable possible à
toutes les pharmacies c'est à dire que
de temps en temps nous recevons de la
part de la NSM qui reçoit des
informations des labos d'un risque de
contingentement une demande
de entre guillemets de bloquer des
stocks de médicaments au cas où il y ait
des ruptures pour les gérer dans des
cadres d'urgence thérapeutique juste
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée de ce
que représente les quotas cela
représente au total
857 références sur la collection de
médicaments qui est estimée à peu près à
24000 références donc vous allez me dire
grosso modo 800 sur 24000 vous me parlez
d'un phénomène épistolaire sauf que le
poids dans la commercialisation de ces
médicaments représente près de 51% de la
valeur du marché de la spécialité
remboursée en France donc c'est
réellement un phénomène d'ampleur
important qui devient croissant année
après année qui pose des questions sur
quels sont les critères qui ont été
définis par les laboratoires pour
attribuer ce volume au marché français
quel est le modèle mathématique qui a
permis de faire une estimation pour
définir quelle est la taille du marché
français qui va servir après de base
d'approvisionnement pour l'ensemble du
marché
troisième point qui nous a semblé
important
d'apporter comme éclairage à la
Commission
il y a une nécessaire amélioration du
partage de l'information
de l'ensemble des acteurs vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics c'est la raison pour
laquelle au niveau de la CSRP nous avons
mis en place un observatoire de la
disponibilité de médicaments qui sera
disponible à partir de début juin pour
les pouvoirs publics afin que l'on
puisse donner une visibilité de
l'ensemble des produits disponibles en
temps réel
pour
pour les pouvoirs publics on est assez
existe bien sur le point c'est que ça
donnera une visibilité des stocks de
produits disponibles à l'instant et de
ceux qui ne le sont pas
la grosse difficulté quand on parle de
pénurie c'est la prévisibilité et la
capacité à anticiper cela donc nous nous
serons capables de donner une vision en
temps réel au pouvoir public en leur
disant ben aujourd'hui sur la collection
de 24000 nous avons tant de niveau de
rupture et les molécules qui sont
rupture sont celles-ci ça va être un
agrégat de près de 70% du marché de la
répartition qui va nous permettre de
donner une vision sur l'ensemble de
territoires donc où on pourra donner à
la fois une vision granulaire à la
molécule à la formule galénique mais
aussi une vision par territoire de telle
manière à ce que le ministère de la
santé puisse avoir une photo en temps
réel de la disponibilité de produits
dernier point sur lequel nous
souhaitions échanger avec vous c'est
l'impératif de la régulation des ventes
directes
c'est un vrai sujet pourquoi parce que
la vente directe correspond à une
logique purement économique et
financière c'est à dire que les
fabricants cibles quelques officines qui
réalisent un chiffre d'affaires élevé et
qui ont la capacité à gérer un volume
important d'achat direct
les équipes nos équipes on va dire
d'approvisionnement ont pour mission et
capacité à pouvoir livrer les 21000
pharmacies or ce qu'on est en train
d'observer c'est que sur certaines
références en tension le canal direct
est de plus en plus utilisé qui perdure
d'une certaine manière la distribution
car nous sommes si vous voulez nous
sommes un espèce d'amortisseur de
distribution puisque de par notre
capacité à stocker et à être capable de
livrer une deux fois par jour les
pharmacies nous assureront une
linéarisation de la mise à disposition
des stocks pour les pharmacies si nous
avons des éléments perturbateurs comme
les ventes directes qui vont être
capables de concentrer un certain nombre
de produits à quota sur certaines
officines on peut remettre en question
l'obligation de traitement égal de
l'ensemble des pharmacies face à des
produits en tension ce sujet est un vrai
sujet qui je pense vous avez dû déjà
on entend parler dans le dans le cadre
des autres auditions qui est
perturbateur à la fois sur la gestion
des stocks mais qui est aussi
perturbateur de l'activité de l'officine
car il faut que vous ayez en tête que
une officine reçoit 5 à 7 livraisons par
jour en sachant comme je vous l'ai
expliqué que 70% des volumes passent par
les grossistes répartiteurs 80% de la
valeur du marché médicament passe au
travers des des administrateurs de la
CSRP néanmoins il y a 5 à 6 livraisons
par jour qui arrivent en plus de la
livraison de leur grossiste répartiteurs
sur des médicaments que nous avons
totalement la possibilité de stocker
dans nos entrepôts et qui permettent
d'assurer un accès égal et équitable à
l'ensemble des pharmacies sans parler de
l'empreinte carbone que cela représente
parce que vous pouvez vous imaginer que
tout cela c'est au travers de livraison
par des messageries etc donc il y a une
vraie logique à peut-être penser le
schéma direct pour l'accès aux
pharmacies voilà l'ensemble des points
que nous étions sur lesquels nous
souhaitions vous apporter un éclairage
j'espère avoir été bref madame la
Présidente et nous sommes complètement à
l'écoute de vos questions sur le sujet
merci je vous remercie beaucoup pour la
brièveté justement de ces propos
liminaires et je passe la parole tout de
suite à
Laurence Cohen rapporteur pour une
première série de questions
oui merci Monsieur pour effectivement la
brièveté de vos propos et en même temps
le fait que vous ayez abordé directement
effectivement les questions qui nous qui
nous préoccupent en tout cas parce que
nous avons été alertés par les
différentes auditions alors peut-être
pour préciser vous l'avez un peu dit
mais peut-être pour avoir un peu plus
d'éléments
il y a donc une distorsion entre les
quantités qui sont mises sur le marché
tel qu'un annoncé par les laboratoires
et les quantités effectivement
réceptionnées par les répartiteurs
est-ce que les données dont vous
disposez sont fiables ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
il y a un outil qui a été créé c'est
l'outil d'épée rupture et mais cet outil
est largement ça pue largement sur le
volontariat est-ce qu'il est
suffisamment utilisé par les grossistes
répartiteurs parce que je crois que vous
y avez accès depuis
2021 et le cas échéant quels sont les
obstacles qui sont identifiés pour
assurer justement un plus large
usage de dépéruptures par les
industriels donc et par vous-même est-ce
que vous pensez que l'utilisation du
déperuptures devraient être rendu
obligatoire et le sens de ma question
c'est obligatoire parce qu'efficace la
troisième la question la troisième
question c'est est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il est possible de construire une
véritable plateforme nationale
susceptible de donner en temps réel une
photographie actualisée de l'ensemble
des stocks disponibles pour chaque
spécialité alors vous avez répondu en
partie puisque vous avez annoncé la
création donc d'un observatoire
début juin si j'ai bien saisi qui serait
donc à disposition des pouvoirs publics
donc est-ce qu'il est dans la nature
est-ce qu'il répond à totalement à la
question que je viens que je viens de
poser vous avez également pour ma
quatrième question vous avez également
abordé
le fait que l'Agence nationale de
sécurité
du médicament
utilisent en fait un dispositif de quota
pour gérer les situations de de pénurie
vous avez dit que
parfois effectivement vous êtes donc
alerté par l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui va donc
bloquer la livraison parce que il y a un
risque de pénurie nous avons été
alerté à ce propos par le directeur
général d'un grand génériqueur français
et qui a dit que finalement ça cette
façon de procéder était pour lui
anxiogène
et que ça ne réglait pas obligatoirement
le problème parce que à la fois il y
avait donc un blocage donc il ne dispose
lui il avait par exemple en tant que
laboratoire il avait un certain nombre
de stocks que lui-même bloquait ou même
vous en bloquez alors que parallèlement
il y avait effectivement des tensions et
qu'on pouvait il pouvait avoir des
alertes d'officine qui manquait de
médicaments donc il trouvait que
finalement c'était une fausse bonne idée
que pensez-vous donc de cette de cette
de cette de ce jugement en réalité et
est-ce que vous vous pensez que vous
êtes finalement équipé pour fluidifier
la gestion des stocks de médicaments en
tension donc avec tous ces processus
pour essayer de régler la question
ma cinquième ma cinquième question c'est
ça concerne la
finalement la responsabilité que vous
pourriez avoir sur les ruptures
d'approvisionnement et je pense
particulièrement aux exportations
parallèles est-ce que vous-même vous
procédez à ces exportations
parallèles et du coup qu'est-ce que ça
peut avoir comme part dans votre
activité dans votre chiffre d'affaires
ma sixième question vous l'avez un peu
abordé c'est la question des shorts
liners qui ne respecte pas l'ensemble
des obligations qui pèsent sur les
acteurs de la répartition est-ce que
justement ça ne vous paraît pas être de
nature à favoriser l'apparition des
phénomènes de rupture et quelle part de
marché représente ces shortliners qui
disparaissent parfois au bout d'un an
d'activité donc c'est aussi une
difficulté ils apparaissent sur le
marché et ils disparaissent un an un an
après alors est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
pour lutter contre ce phénomène essayez
d'améliorer en amont les contrôles au
niveau de l'autorisation notamment en
renforçant les barrières à l'entrée de
nouveaux arrivants sur le marché
spécifique et celui de la répartition
et enfin j'arrive à ma dernière question
il me semble et dans les chiffres que
vous nous avez donné
j'ai ressenti exactement la même chose
mais peut-être que j'ai j'ai mal
interprété vos données les grossistes
répartiteurs semblent très peu présent
dans les flux de médicaments vers
l'hôpital alors que pourtant l'hôpital
est particulièrement touchée et presque
encore plus touché ou même que le
presque est de trop plus touché par les
pénuries que les officines et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut en conclure au delà du fait
que les produits distribués dans ces
deux circuits ne sont pas
obligatoirement les mêmes mais je pense
quand même que ça n'est pas du tout
l'explication satisfaisante ce qu'il
faudrait donner voilà je vous remercie
par avance pour vos réponses vous avez
la parole
très bien
bon donc cette question
peut-être balayer les plus simples et
puis aller
en montant le degré de difficulté
par rapport au sujet la question numéro
3 que vous avez posé concernant une
plateforme nationale donnant une
visibilité sur la disponibilité de
médicaments en temps réel c'est
justement le but de l'Observatoire que
nous allons mettre à disposition à
partir de début juin ça fait maintenant
six mois que nous travaillons sur le
développement de cet outil qui va nous
permettre en temps réel sur l'ensemble
de la spécialité remboursée de donner
une visibilité à la fois par molécule
formule galénique par territoire ce sont
des choses qui existent déjà dans
d'autres industries qui vont permettre
qui vont nous permettre
d'étayer les discussions que l'on a que
ce soit avec les laboratoires ou que
soit avec le ministère de la Santé basé
sur des faits des chiffres en temps réel
et non pas
sur des légendes urbaines ou des
qu'endira-t-on je pense qu'il est très
important dans ce débat
d'apporter des faits concrets pour
savoir où est-ce qu'on doit monopoliser
notre attention et notre action tout en
sachant que derrière c'est un point que
nous avons défendu au nom de la CSRP
dans nos discussions avec les pouvoirs
publics il faut aussi avoir une clarté
sur la définition de quels sont les
produits les plus importants ce qu'on
appelle les MITM
quels sont les produits les plus
importants sur lesquels on doit avoir un
suivi plus actif mais aussi une
réactivité plus importante en cas de
risque de rupture
je pense que ce sujet là dans tous les
métiers
que ce soit de la distribution de
produits
de santé ou d'autres produits ça permet
de focaliser notre attention sur les
problèmes qui sont on va dire les plus
importants et qui peuvent avoir le plus
d'impact pour nous concitoyens donc la
réponse à la question 3 nous pensons que
l'outil que nous allons mettre à
disposition pourraient être une réponse
nous allons le mettre à disposition pour
la première fois dès le début juin c'est
un outil qui est géré par un tiers
externe pour éviter tout risque on va
dire de collusion par rapport à des
questions de concurrence donc nous
mettons un accès facilité un tiers à un
tiers qui va récupérer l'ensemble de ces
données nous donner une visibilité donc
par rapport à ça je pense que la
question 3 madame l'a rapporteur je
pense avoir répondu à votre
interrogation
distorsion annoncée sur la première
question vous me posez une
questionniez par rapport à la
dissertation distorsion annoncée entre
les volumes mises à disposition les
volumes distribués est-ce que nos
données sont fiables 100%
. il y a rien à cacher
on est obligé d'offrir un niveau de
traçabilité dans la distribution des
produits de médicaments sur lequel il y
a un suivi des produits qui permet de
voir réellement les lots à quel endroit
ils ont été livrés de telle manière à ce
que si jamais nous devons effectuer des
retraits nous puissions avoir
l'information pour savoir à quel
officier nous avons livré ces produits
là
sur des perructures je vais laisser la
parole à Emmanuelle qui est un meilleur
spécialiste que moi sur le sujet
sur le déperupteur donc le DP rupture
tous les toutes les entreprises
adhérentes à la Chambre Syndicale sont
utilisent le déperuptures et le
renseigne quand elles peuvent le
renseigner la question en fait du
déperuptures c'est de savoir s'il est
rempli renseigné alimenté de manière
exhaustive de la part des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
et
notamment sur les causes des ruptures
sur la durée
et sur la question du retour à la
normale parce qu'en vérité c'est ça les
informations qui sont les plus
intéressantes en matière de rupture
d'approvisionnement c'est savoir
pourquoi le produit voilà quand il est
quand il sera de nouveau disponible donc
le dépuratures c'est un très bon outil
après il faut simplement qu'il soit
obligatoire pour tout le monde et que
les informations qui soient dedans soit
exhaustive utile fiable parce que la
question par exemple du retour à la
normale c'est une question qui est un
point qui est très évolutif vous allez
avoir dans un premier temps par exemple
une information selon laquelle le
produit sera disponible dans 15 jours et
puis tout d'un coup on va ça va passer à
6 semaines
sans que vous ayez nécessairement
l'information c'est d'autant plus
difficile à utiliser que les grossistes
répartiteurs à travers leur système
d'information
fournissent de l'information aux
pharmaciens quand un pharmacien passe
commande via un outil qui s'appelle
Pharma ml et dont vous avez déjà entendu
parler à l'occasion de l'audition
notamment des pharmaciens d'officine
format ml ne produit aucune information
de manière autonome format ml c'est un
vecteur donc format email faut aller
l'alimenter comment on alimente Pharma
email pour qui communique de
l'information et qui permettent de de
véhiculer de l'information vers le
pharmacien de cuisine et ben on va aller
chercher sur le site de la NSM ou dans
le déperuptures voilà et c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne et si ces informations
ne sont pas exhaustives ne sont pas
précises ne sont pas fiables et bien
l'information véhiculée par Famin email
pâtira des mêmes défauts
donc le déperuptures c'est un excellent
outil il faut s'appuyer dessus
certainement et peut-être le développer
la meilleure
pardon
concernant le sujet sur l'exportation
c'est pas une surprise votre question on
s'imaginait bien que vous alliez aborder
ce point
je crois qu'il faut là aussi apporter
des données fiables et ça fait partie
des légendes urbaines qui circulent sur
certains premièrement
ce sont des dénonciations graves qui ne
reposent sur aucune preuve aucun élément
à ce jour au canadérant de la Chambre
syndicale a été mise en cause par une
autorité de contrôle pour des pratiques
d'exportation concernant nos ESP en
effet nos 175 agences sont régulièrement
audités que soit par des agences
régionales de santé ou par la NSM pour
vérifier les pratiques que nous avons
il est
assez surprenant de voir que depuis
plusieurs mois la NSM interdit
l'exportation de certains de références
il s'agit d'une mesure de précaution qui
a été mise en place par rapport à une
situation de tension installée on
pourrait prendre l'exemple par exemple
des corticoïdes sur lesquels depuis
trois ans
les exportations sont totalement
interdites
ça n'a pas empêché d'avoir des ruptures
le paracétamol par exemple sur les
formules infantiles qui a été un grave
problème dont nous avons souffert durant
le dernier trimestre de l'année 2022 il
y a jamais eu une exportation de ce
produit là donc je pense que là dessus
il faut
remettre l'église au son du village
regardez quels sont réellement les
sources d'approvisionnement quelle est
la taille du marché quels sont les
besoins du marché et quels sont les
capacités que l'on a à s'adapter à des
évolutions saisonnières des besoins de
nos compatriotes et assez souvent c'est
là où on va trouver
les problèmes de nos ruptures
juste à titre d'information je tenais à
le rappeler
nous ne communiquons pas ces chiffres
dans le cadre de la CSRP mais on lors
d'une précédente audition d'une
commission sénatoriale sur les ruptures
médicaments nous avions communiqué un
chiffre qui est toujours d'actualité
c'est à dire que l'exportation ça
représente moins de 3% de notre activité
donc ça reste quand même une activité
vraiment très très marginale sur lequel
nous sommes excessivement contrôlés il y
a des processus établis des contrôles
établis qui permettent d'assurer que
cette
activité ne nuit pas à
l'approvisionnement de l'ensemble des
pharmacies en France
concernant le problème sur le sujet de
la NSM peut-être Emmanuel vous pouvez
les contingents NSM vous pouvez
intervenir oui alors c'est un sujet sur
lequel il faut peut-être clarifier un
petit peu les les
conserves les ce que vous avez pu
entendre dire donc il y a il y a eu
effectivement des contingentements qui
ont été imposés au laboratoire
pharmaceutique et vous avez évoqué les
propos d'un directeur général d'un gros
génériqueur donc
la NSM demandant effectivement assez
laboratoires de garder par dere une
quantité de produits disponible à
mobiliser en cas de besoin du côté de la
répartition la NSM n'a pas vraiment
demandé aux répartiteur de faire des
stocks de sécurité en revanche elle leur
a demandé de contingenter les produits
livrés aux pharmacies
pour faire en sorte que les pharmaciens
ne constituent pas à leur niveau des
stocks de sécurité et pour faire en
sorte que le peu de produits disponible
sur les marchés le marché soit
distribués de façon la plus équitable
possible alors ça juste c'est un jour
prend parce que j'ai vu un certain
nombre de personnes tickets étaient sous
forme d'un nombre de boîtes à attribuer
par pharmacie de telle manière à ne pas
créer un espèce d'effet DALO au moment
de la mise à disposition des stocks et
de s'assurer qu'on était capable de
livrer l'ensemble des 21000 pharmacies
de par une limitation entre guillemets
saine permettant un libre accès à
l'ensemble des pharmacies à ces produits
pardon Emmanuel voilà donc juste
permettez-moi pour bien préciser ma
question donc par les explications que
vous nous donnez les premiers arrivés ne
sont pas les premiers servis
c'est le but c'est le but de la mesure
c'est de faire en sorte que tout le
monde puisse avoir un peu de produits
sachant que tous les produits ne sont
pas disponibles je parle de la
distribution mise en place par les
grossistes répartiteurs parce que au
niveau des ventes directes je ne sais
pas comment ça se passe
il faudrait poser la question au
laboratoire
on l'a peut-être pas assez mis en avant
dans nos populations de cadres dans nos
entreprises la première population sont
des pharmaciens qui t'ont qui ont un
rôle c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas des
distributeurs comme on distribuerait du
nutella ou des pâtes on a derrière tout
un tas de règles que vous avez expliqué
dans le cadre de nos obligations
d'acteurs de santé publique qui doivent
être respectés dans le cadre desquels
nos pharmaciens responsables agissent et
quand on est dans des cas de situation
de contingentement tel que nous avons pu
connaître sur certaines molécules nous
recevons des directives de la part de la
NSM qui derrière entraîne chez nous dans
nos établissements dans l'ensemble des
175 établissements la mise en place de
règles de contrôle sur la distribution
de telle manière telle que vous
l'expliquez que ce soit pas le premier
servi qui récupère l'ensemble des stocks
et assurer une libre distribution et je
pense que dans le cadre de la discussion
que nous avions sur la répartition entre
les ventes entre les grossistes
répartiteurs les ventes directes c'est
un vrai avantage d'avoir des grossistes
répartiteurs là-dessus parce que nous
sommes capables dans ce cadre-là
d'établir des règles de libre accès à
tout le monde de telle manière à ce que
l'ensemble des pharmacies de France
puisse être livrés et que ce soit pas
uniquement l'intérêt de certains qui
prévaut versus l'intérêt général la
première des règles de de
contingentement
utilisé par la répartition dans ce genre
de situation c'est celle qui consiste à
ne livrer que ses clients numéro 1 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que un
pharmacien
généralement à
un fournisseur principal un grossiste
répartiteur numéro 1 et un gros si ce
n'est répartiteur numéro 2 dans les
situations de tension la NSM nous
demande de de de faire des quotas des
contingentements et bien la première
règle que nous appliquons c'est celle
qui consiste à dire je ne livre que mes
clients numéro 1 pas mon client numéro 2
ça je pour éviter encore une fois ce
phénomène qui consisterait pour un
pharmacien à aller frapper à toutes les
portes pour récupérer le produit donc il
a son il a son son distributeur
principal auquel il s'adresse et chacun
applique ce genre de règle après les les
quantités
la NSM nous nous demande de les limiter
il y a eu je crois sur certains produits
une imitation à 50% en disant vous
limitez à 50% de la commande voilà
chacun
en fonction des systèmes d'information
qui utilisent calibre et limite les
commandes de des pharmaciens pour
respecter les demandes de la NSM
votre sixième question portée sur les
short liner le respect des obligations
de santé publique leur part de marché la
responsabilité sur les ruptures etc
écouter sur les parts de marché il y a
un panélis qui est utilisé dans la dans
la profession qui permet d'avoir une
vision un petit peu sur comment le
marché se répartit entre les différents
grossistes répartiteurs qui sert après
au laboratoire pour pouvoir attribuer
les quotas dans le cas de la discussion
que nous avions sur la politique de
quota ce que remonte le Gers on appelle
ça le Gers ce que les informations qui
sont remontées par le Gers font état
d'une part de marché de l'ordre de 3 à 3
et demi pour cent sur la distribution de
de spécialités de spécialités
remboursées
responsabilité sur le rupture il est
compliqué pour nous de vous donner une
visibilité une visibilité là-dessus
il est très clair que nous sommes en
faveur les grossistes répartiteurs à ce
que il y ait une clarification de cette
profession
parce que nous sommes capables de
respecter des obligations d'acteurs de
santé publique comme l'expliquait madame
la Présidente avec près de 90% des
stocks disponibles livrables en 24
heures où nous sommes capables d'offrir
15 jours de stock sur les produits qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas en tension
ou en rupture
je crois que cela mériterait d'être
démontré par l'ensemble des acteurs de
la profession
et sur ce point là je me suis quicon
pour juger mais nous nous sommes très
clairement audités très régulièrement et
nous nous apporterons portons à chaque
audit la démonstration du respect de nos
obligations d'acteurs de santé publique
peut-être peut-être pour compléter
aujourd'hui des shortliners il y en a 41
41 agence qui sont des shortliners qui
sont pas adhérents à la Chambre
Syndicale
la question de savoir comment traiter le
sujet et très complexe parce qu'ils ont
le même statut juridique que les
grossistes répartiteurs
donc la piste que vous évoquiez de
durcir un petit peu les les conditions
d'obtention d'une autorisation
d'ouverture d'établissement c'est
certainement une piste à creuser
après
il y a eu par exemple un certain nombre
de de d'initiatives pour essayer de
trouver comment contraindre davantage
etc etc comment modifier les obligations
de service public pour faire en sorte
éventuellement que ce soit plus
difficile pour un
un à chaque fois on n'a pas abouti c'est
vraiment un problème difficile et de là
à dire que ils ont une part de
responsabilité dans les ruptures
d'approvisionnement là c'est ce que
vient de dire Laurent on n'a pas
d'éléments objectifs qui nous permettent
d'affirmer ça c'est très difficile mais
la piste de l'autorisation est peut-être
celle qu'il faudrait creuser pour que ce
soit plus exigeant
dernière question qui est un petit peu
complexe pour vous répondre qui concerne
la présence des grossistes répartiteurs
dans les fluos hospitaliers nous sommes
présents même si comme vous le mettiez
en avant
pas d'une manière aussi prépondérante
que nous le sommes dans le cadre de la
distribution dans les pharmacies en
effet tel que vous le
l'évoquiez dans votre question
les produits utilisés dans les hôpitaux
sont ne sont pas forcément les produits
utilisant les pharmacies de ville
néanmoins de plus en plus les
laboratoires font évoluer les gammes de
spécialités remboursées pour que ce soit
des produits plus facilement injectables
donc en effet on observe de plus en plus
des flux des pharmacies d'hôpitaux qui
sont transférées vers la pharmacie de
ville et qui est une tendance qui a qui
est en train de s'accélérer sur les ces
dernières années pour faciliter l'accès
au traitement des patients et qui ne
soit pas obligé d'aller se rendre dans
une pharmacie d'hôpital un certain
nombre de produits sont mis à
disposition au travers des pharmacies de
ville qui était auparavant des produits
où il y avait besoin d'une intervention
d'une infirmière pour l'injecter avec
des stylos injectables etc et donc qui
permet d'accélérer la distribution du
médicament vers la pharmacie de ville
sur les pharmacies d'hôpitaux en effet
si j'ai une question qui se pose et je
pense que vous aurez sûrement un certain
nombre de pistes à proposer dans le
cadre de vos travaux pour voir de quelle
manière nous pourrions être sollicité de
manière plus importante à l'avenir
très bien merci je vais passer la parole
à mes collègues Corinne Imbert
si la présidente merci messieurs pour
vos éclairages
alors d'abord pardonnez-moi d'être
arrivé un petit peu en retard et j'ai
loupé le début de de vos propos
introductifs
et je suis arrivé au moment où vous
faisiez un peu de reproche aux
pharmaciens d'officine d'acheter en
direct
ça c'est pas très bien bon voilà au
contraire au contraire je dis que les
grossistes répartiteurs sont une
solution pour faciliter la vie des
officiers donc vous aviez loupé vous
aviez raté une partie de mon propos
liminaire madame j'ai retenu que ce qui
va un petit peu choqué
ceci étant ceci étant en introduction
j'aurais évidemment saluer le travail
des grossissent répartiteurs leur
importance dans la cheminement du
médicament c'est pas vous que je vais
réexpliquer l'importance du réseau
pharmaceutique le maillage territorial
l'aménagement du territoire etc et votre
rôle au quotidien vous avez besoin d'un
médicament si vous l'avez en stock le
matin le pharmacien de la part vous
pouvez le récupérer dans la soirée dans
votre officine ce qui est un service aux
patient énorme qui est important et ce
qui fait toute la valeur de
l'organisation et la logistique qui qui
existe dans notre pays depuis des années
même si même si pour des raisons
économiques là aussi puisque on est tous
embarqué dans dans le secteur du
médicament même si le service le nombre
de livraisons par jour à diminuer le
service c'est un petit peu
un petit peu non pas détérioré c'est pas
ça mais a été un peu réduit mais ça
s'entend les pharmaciens de l'entente et
les patients peuvent quand même
rapidement récupérer médicament qui
pouvait leur manquer
merci d'avoir confirmé que vous
appliquez un contingentement alors je
voudrais d'abord saluer aussi je pense
que ça avait été dit en tout cas c'est
lui le service apporté via farm AML sur
j'allais dire la disponibilité non pas
le stock mais la disponibilité d'un
médicament à l'instant T chez les
grossistes quand le pharmacien va
commander son médicament
merci d'avoir confirmé qui avait bien un
contingentement puisqu'il apparaît
disponible vous commandez 10 boîtes et
vous allez recevoir que deux sur le
comptage entre moi à 50% je pense que ça
doit être variable alors sauf si pas de
chance c'était le des dernières boîtes
ou je mettrai un bémol par rapport à la
question de de la rapporteur et votre
réponse ce sont quand même bien sûr et
c'est très bien ce contingentement moi
je le salue puisque ça permet justement
que certains
grosses officines sur stock et au
détriment du reste du territoire ceci
étant si vous êtes le 150e pharmacien de
la matinée à passer commande peut-être
qu'il y en aura plus réellement voilà
donc c'est c'est pas premier servi et
vous prenez tout le stock et
heureusement qu'il y a ce
contingentement par contre si vous
passez votre commande à midi et que
certains l'ont passé entre 9h et 10
heures ceux qui l'ont passé leur
commande entre 9h et 10h le matin en
plus de chance d'être approvisionnés que
si vous passez mais ça c'est des ces
côtés officiels c'est l'organisation
c'est voilà
vous avez évoqué 41 short liner
combien combien
sont rattachés un grossiste répartiteur
même si sur deux activités deux entités
des facturations différentes vous avez
des grossistes répartiteur qui dans leur
je suis un peu quand même
pas des rangs à la Chambre syndicale
alors par exemple
on peut citer des noms
c'est encore plus subtil alors ça
expliquez-moi la différence alors
maintenant tiens alors je ne sais pas je
ne suis pas de le CP donc je sais quand
même enfin ça n'est pas un short liner
au sens où l'établissement est un
établissement de répartition
pharmaceutique et qui va livrer dans le
cadre des obligations de service public
si la relation se situe dans ce cadre
donc dans ce cadre
le le pharmacien pourra commander un à
une agence ECP un médicament et OCP
alors je parle de l'OCP je suis pas là
pour défendre au CP en particulier je
suis à fond c'est juste un exemple je
veux dire que après chaque grossiste
répartiteur outre son service cœur de
métier celui de la distribution des
médicaments remboursables dans le cadre
des obligations de service public c'est
bien ça le cœur de métier de la
répartition pharmaceutique à côté chacun
à tout le loisir de développer des
offres commerciales
qui sont divers et variés dans laquelle
il va proposer un service différent aux
pharmaciens mais qui n'empêchera jamais
le pharmacien d'avoir accès aux
médicaments dans le cadre des
obligations de services publics définis
par le code de la santé publique ça à
aucun moment ça vient interférer avec
l'activité de grossiste répartiteur et à
aucun moment un grossiste répartiteur se
réfugiera non ça c'est une offre c'est
enfin je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas
du tout un short liner
un short liner c'est un établissement
pharmaceutique qui a un statut de
grossiste répartiteur et je dirais dont
nous considérons parce que c'est
l'expérience l'observation le ce qu'on
observe et qui n'est pas en capacité de
d'assurer les obligations de services
publics dans leur totalité c'est à dire
qu'il a pas toute la gamme de produits
c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle les
shortliners versus les fulliners mais
encore une fois il n'y a pas de short
liner c'est-à-dire d'agence de
répartition qui soit un short liner qui
soit
affilié à un grossiste répartiteur de la
Chambre syndicale
ceci étant quand est traduit je suis
désolé de je sais que tout est
enregistré mais c'est pas un exemple que
je connais un tout petit peu mais j'ai
pu effectivement il y a peut-être
quelque chose qui a évolué dans le temps
puisqu'à un moment donné c'était bien
une activité de short liner qui était
présentée par ce service là et moi je
veux bien entendre que c'est un service
du grossiste répartiteur sauf que la
facturation elle est pas au CP
donc alors après c'est pas eux qu'on
nous disions mais je dirais chercher la
réponse et l'éclairage parce que pour
moi il y a deux il y a un service
peut-être une activité commerciale mais
la facturation n'est pas au CP donc d'où
ma question mais mais je je
interrogé aussi les
représentants de
CP pour qu'on m'explique également dans
le cadre de la commission d'enquête mais
en attendant parce que j'entends votre
offre commerciale d'un grossiste
répartiteur mais en attendant si c'était
ça ça serait une facturation au CP me
semble-t-il mais peut-être que je me
trompe voilà c'était pour savoir donc je
peux pas répondre à cette question je
n'en sais rien d'accord écoutez en tout
cas voilà
[Musique]
mais j'entends tout ce que vous me dites
et j'entends je connais un petit peu les
les responsabilités et l'admission de
service public des grossistes
répartiteurs c'était double question une
activité consiste répartiteur et à côté
je porte une société qui a une activité
il y a quand même un lien étroit me
semble-t-il entre les deux c'est pour ça
que je souhaitais d'où ma question et
votre éclairage mais j'entends votre
impossibilité à me répondre il y a pas
de souci là-dessus mais j'essaierai de
mieux comprendre par rapport à votre à
votre remarque une question sur
l'observatoire si vous me permettez à la
présidente qui sera destinataire des
données de l'Observatoire s'il vous
plaît nous avons prévu de le donner de
le mettre à disposition du Ministère de
la Santé grade sur demande nous avons
des interlocuteurs réguliers qui nous
demandent des informations et donc ils
auront accès à ces informations
l'assistant sur le fait que c'est un
tiers de un tiers externe qui aura accès
à ces informations parce que bien
évidemment
on n'a pas le droit en termes de droit
concurrentiel d'avoir accès à des
informations disponibilités de nos
concurrents donc c'est ce tiers là de
confiance qui va pouvoir agréger
l'ensemble des informations et les
mettre après à disposition
oui alors non pas exactement d'abord
premier point pour revenir sur votre
question initiale ça sera sur demande de
la même manière que les industriels ont
mis en place trackstock
c'est sur demande de la NSM pour une
catégorie de produits ou pour une
référence de données
des références de médicaments
remboursables on est autour de 10-12000
donc fournir des fichiers avec 10 12.000
références et des et des des
disponibilités à côté je pense que ça
serait intraitable donc l'idée c'est de
fournir sur demande de la NSM notamment
des éléments de disponibilité
ça sera pas des éléments de volume parce
que nos stocks par définition ils
évoluent d'une journée même pas d'une
journée à l'autre du matin au soir le
matin on a sans produits le soir on peut
en avoir plus que 0 bon c'est notre
métier qui veut ça donc l'idée c'est
juste d'avoir une vision
par agence de répartition si le produit
est physiquement détenu dans l'agence ou
pas à ce stade c'est un c'est ça le
premier état de développement du produit
et il sera intéressant parce que il
permettra dans la durée de voir
l'évolution pour une référence donnée je
veux dire par là que vous vous
intéressez à une référence
mettons d'amoxicilline ou de corticoïdes
vous regardez ce qu'il en était il y a
trois semaines la France était verte il
y a 15 jours il y avait déjà des points
où c'était rouge et aujourd'hui c'est
presque entièrement rouge donc là il est
temps d'alerter très rapidement les
autorités pour leur dire là on a un
souci sur ce produit la disponibilité se
dégrade de plus en plus
voilà juste une précision par rapport
aux commentaires manuels et votre point
sur les volumes c'est à dire que ça
donnera pas une vision sur il y a tant
de milliers de bottes disponibles mais
ça permettra de dire à ce jour temps
d'établissement ont de la disponibilité
de ce produit ou non pas et donc ça
permettra de donner un éclairage au-delà
de la perception de quelques pharmaciens
à droite à gauche mais de donner une
visibilité sur l'ensemble des
établissements de répartition
pharmaceutique combien d'établissements
ont des stocks disponibles après en
effet la grosse question qui se pose sur
les volumes c'est toujours la même c'est
à dire que à un moment T vous pouvez
avoir un volume suffisant pour
approvisionner le marché français pour
peu qu'il y ait des rumeurs de rupture
et Madame Abba vous connaissez bien
l'histoire puisque vous êtes
pharmacienne
automatiquement le premier réflexe
d'information c'est dès qu'il entend une
rumeur de rupture poom on passe des
stocks on se met un stock de côté et on
se protège
ce qui est un réflexe normal je dirais
dans la profession donc ça va donner une
visibilité à un instant T mais cet
instanté le lendemain peut-être
différent c'est la difficulté de ces
observatoires c'est que c'est une photo
à un instant présent
des questions du coup complémentaires au
moins donc je pense que c'est interactif
là
du coup comment vous pouvez assurer les
15 jours de stock si vous avez pas de
visibilité sur les volumes mais qu'il y
a c'est une très bonne question
je vais vous prendre un exemple qu'on a
tous vécu je vous remercie de m'avoir
posé mais je vous ai je vais essayer de
vous y répondre de manière très concrète
on était tous présents le 10 mars 2020
les volumes de paracétamol que nous
vendions étaient d'un volume X
tout d'un coup sur internet comment ça
circulé des rumeurs en disant ah ben le
paracétamol va être indispensable dans
la lutte contre le covid etc qu'est-ce
que ça entraînait et les pharmaciens
peuvent en témoigner du jour au
lendemain on s'est retrouvé avec des
queues de patient pour acheter du
paracétamol qui je vous rappelle est un
médicament qui est aussi un OTC des
livrables en libre-service à l'époque
c'était même derrière le comptoir
disponible donc comment est-ce que vous
définissez le volume sur des produits
sur lesquels vous n'avez pas d'activité
saisonnière ou on va dire que cette
histoire de rumeurs est une activité
saisonnière donc les volumes que nous
avions à l'époque avant que surgit ce
type de rumeurs
correspondait à un volume régulier et
puis après durant toute la période covid
on a tous vécu ces moments où il y en
avait certains qui nous disaient faut
consommer tel médicament parce qu'il y a
des tests en Italie qui permettent de
savoir que ça va protéger que ça évite
d'avoir des embolies pulmonaires etc et
tout d'un coup moi je vais pas vous
citer non de molécules mais on a des
noms des molécules ou moi j'ai
expérimenté ça dans mon entreprise nous
vendions un volume de d'une centaine de
boîtes par mois
où nous avons vendu dans une journée
2000 boîtes qui étaient le stock que
nous avions à disposition et donc si
nous avions eu 200 000 boîtes ce jour-là
nous aurions vendu 200 000 boîtes donc
on est capable dans le cadre d'une
distribution régulière dans le cadre
d'événements récurrents non exceptionnel
d'avoir une visibilité sur quelle est la
prévisibilité de la demande
comment savoir des événements sur des
risques de rupture créant un halo une
rumeur sur le marché là derrière les
volumes s'envolent il n'y a plus aucune
logique il y a plus aucun modèle
statistique permettant d'anticiper cette
demande là et en effet on se retrouve
dans des cas de rupture après soyons
clairs aussi entre nous
nos modèles statistiques de prévision de
la demande permettent de répondre à 99%
des problèmes des problématiques
d'approvisionnement
quand on a des cas exceptionnels on sait
pas y répondre
alors mais ça parlons-nous clairement
c'est l'histoire de la distribution du
médicament depuis la nuit des temps
c'est à dire qu'en effet quand vous avez
une phase on va dire où vous avez une
montée de grip et bien tout d'un coup un
certain nombre de médicaments grippaux
vise à manquer madame en tant que
pharmacienne vous pouvez en témoigner ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui ça date depuis
des années et des années en revanche je
crois que par rapport aux questions que
vous posiez sur la mise à disposition de
stock et le fait qu'on est ces stocks
disponible sur l'ensemble des
territoires du territoire permet d'être
un amortisseur rupture
tout comme un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
sur une montée des stocks chez les
dépositaires de telle manière à assurer
un approvisionnement régulier c'est
aussi une manière de répondre et d'être
un amortisseur aux rupture
ça
j'entends tout à fait votre propos
puisque vous vous isolez la question
conjoncturelle la question structurelle
de la pénurie du médicament est-ce que
votre réponse signifie que sur les
questions structurelles le pénurie de
médicaments vous êtes complètement
absent et vous n'avez aucune
responsabilité
est-ce que dans votre activité vous êtes
en capacité de répondre en dehors des
pics de consommation ou parler de la
pandémie évidemment c'est retrouver dans
des voilà
une forme complètement inhabituelle de
consommation mais sur un trade normal il
ne reste pas moins qu'on a des pénuries
de médicaments et donc il y a pas que le
paracétamol ou l'amoxicilline il y a
tout un tas de médicaments on a des anti
épilétiques on a des antibiotiques il y
a pas eu d'épidémie d'épilepsie a priori
il y a ma connaissance le diabète c'est
pareil même si bon voilà on peut trouver
des facteurs de risque de tous ordres
mais donc
la question de la pénurie c'est pas que
l'amoxicilline enfin les antibiotiques
par exemple et que la question du
paracétamol et donc sur les autres
médicaments
vous êtes en capacité
en dehors des situations conjoncturelles
d'assurer ce fameux 15 jours
thématiquement c'est pas pour rien que
je vous partage avec vous des données de
la profession qui disent que à partir du
moment où on a du stock de disponible et
mis à disposition du grossiste répartisé
on est capable de livrer n'importe où en
France à n'importe quel moment deux fois
par jour 3 fois par jour en fonction des
contraintes qu'on nous demande bien sûr
notre système le démontre au quotidien
je veux dire on est quand même avec un
système de santé qui je crois durant
cette période de pandémie elle a mis
cette pandémie a mis en lumière à la
fois ce qui faisait la force et nos
faiblesses de notre de notre système de
santé
on a été présent tous les jours c'est
pas pour rien que la distribution que ce
soit des masques des tests des
auto-testes des vaccins sont passés au
travers des grossistes répartiteurs
parce que nous sommes une distribution
fiable
qui assure une qualité de distribution
assurant aux pharmaciens que les
médicaments qui leur arrivent sont des
médicaments totalement administrables
pour nos concitoyens donc pour vous
répondre
c'est pas une question de rejeter la
responsabilité sur quiconque ce que je
vous dis c'est que quand les médicaments
sont disponibles à
99,5%, nous les livrons dans les deux
heures qui suivent
et ça ce sont des données prouvées
madame comme pharmacienne vous pouvez le
témoigner c'est notre métier de tous les
jours
et nous le faisons parfaitement nous
sommes challengers nous sommes audités
par l'ensemble des autorités de santé
pour s'assurer que nous respectons nos
obligations de santé publique et je
crois que si nous avons eu autant de
responsabilités confiées par le
ministère de la Santé et nous sommes
fiers qu'on nous est confiés ces
responsabilités dans le cadre de la
lutte de la pandémie parce que ça
démontre la fiabilité de nos
distributions vous comprenez bien qu'on
essaie de de comprendre ce qui dans ce
qui nous est témoigné d'un certain
nombre d'interlocuteurs est-ce que vous
nous répondez là ce qu'elle est la part
de la réalité ou du vrai et notamment un
certain nombre de de laboratoires de
fabricants disent nous on a libéré les
stocks
et on comprend pas ça n'arrive pas dans
les pharmacies on l'a entendu plusieurs
fois et donc moi j'essaie de comprendre
un peu parce que sur la question sur les
événements conjoncturels je peux le
comprendre tout à fait c'est de toute
façon par définition à un moment de
désordre et imprévisible mais c'est
surtout ce qui est de fonctionnement
classique on a quand même des pénuries
et on nous dit mais moi j'ai libéré les
stocks voilà c'est ce qui est déclaré et
d'ailleurs on a des déclarations
ministères ou de la NSM qui nous disent
nous on nous a dit il y a plus de
pénurie c'est bien les laboratoires qui
témoignent de de la pénurie ou pas donc
vous comprenez on essaie de comprendre
on a des pays comme les Pays-Bas par
exemple qui ont imposé des stocks et qui
valent de deux mois pour l'élaboratoires
et pour les distributeurs donc et donc
on témoigne du fait que ça peut être
aussi une option même si on sait que
c'est un coup parce qu'il y a des
questions de coût dans tout ça qui
disent stockage des coups de stockage
donc voilà non madame la Présidente
comme vous le disiez dans votre propos
liminaire le
le sujet
des ruptures de médicaments est un sujet
complexe
moi je peux prendre l'engagement pour
l'ensemble des grossistes répartiteurs
que je représente que quand les stocks
sont mises à disposition
il est impossible de prouver que nous
n'avons pas réalisé notre métier je vous
le dis notre distribution est certifiée
contrôlée par des pharmaciens
responsables qui mettent en jeu leur
diplôme pour assurer que l'ensemble de
nos clients soit servi
c'est une distribution très spécifique
comme je vous le disais en vulgarisant
on distribue pas des pâtes ou des ou des
gâteaux ce sont des produits de
distribution spécifique derrière
lesquelles nous appliquons des règles
établies par le Code de la Santé que
nous respectons sur lequel nous sommes
audités et qui font partie de nos
responsabilités il est très clair que
assez souvent sur ces produits là nous
émettons des contingentements parce que
comme l'expliquer madame en tant que
pharmacienne le risque que l'on a c'est
que le premier qui est accès au stock
sur le premier service qui prennent tous
les stocks pour tous les pharmaciens ce
qui explique à certains moments sur des
produits contingentement à NSM comme
l'expliquait Emmanuel nous mettons des
maximum de boîtes par pharmacien de
telle manière assurée une distribution
régulière de ces produits là donc pour
vous répondre le plus distinctement
possible et j'ai prêté serment sur
l'honneur de la véracité de mes réponses
oui nous sommes capables quand les
produits sont disponibles d'assurer une
distribution à 99,5 100% des produits
sur l'ensemble du territoire français et
les sujets sont des vrais sujets d'accès
au marché
de définition de certains quotas de
médicaments ou je pense que c'est un
sujet qui je pense ne doit pas échapper
aux travaux de votre commission pour
définir de quelle manière ces quotas
sont définis pour le marché français car
c'est
870 et quelques produits qui
représentent 51% de la taille du marché
français il faudrait bien qu'on nous
explique de quelle manière ils sont les
volumes affectés au marché français sont
définies car là aussi c'est pas
uniquement ça qui est la raison des
ruptures mais c'est sûrement un ensemble
de raisons donc le sujet
des ruptures de médicaments en France
n'est pas un problème qui a une cause
unique il y a différentes causes et la
grosse difficulté de des résultats des
travaux de cette commission c'est de
savoir un petit peu d'attribuer à chacun
des leviers quels sont les raisons qui
peuvent expliquer exactement j'espère
avoir été précis madame la Présidente
je vous étrange parce que rassurez-vous
on depuis le temps que que nous
avons des des auditions et puis de toute
façon y compris en avoir des auditions
parce que on s'intéresse au sujet en
tant que parlementaire on a bien compris
que c'était multifactoriel donc là
dessus je vous rassure la Commission ne
va pas se fourvoyer moi je par rapport à
ce que vous dites donc les choses sont
claires donc c'est pas une histoire vous
avez bien dit que à partir du moment où
vous aviez les médicaments
disponibles c'est-à-dire qui arrive chez
vous il y a pas de sujet en réalité ils
sont distribués et vous êtes donc les
contrôles en amont se font les contrôles
voir continuer se font donc votre
problème qui est notre problème c'est
plutôt effectivement
le la masse de ou le volume plus
exactement des médicaments que vous
allez pouvoir recevoir pour les ventiler
sur les territoires c'est ça donc c'est
une responsabilité plus élaboratoires
des industries voilà
ma question sur les chiffres que vous
nous avez donné si j'ai bien compris
y compris après en ayant répondu à l'une
de mes questions c'est que les chiffres
que vous m'avez donné ne prennent pas en
compte parce que ça m'a semblé être
beaucoup plus faible voire minimum les
chiffres au niveau de l'hôpital de
livraison de l'hôpital les chiffres que
vous nous avez donnés sont plutôt les
chiffres uniquement des officines des
pharmacies de ville voilà et la
troisième question vous parlez d'un
tiers
qui va donc intervenir par rapport aux
données etc je voudrais avoir des
précisions sur ce tiers est-ce que ce
tiers est un cabinet conseil est-ce que
se tiers est quelqu'un d'autre donc je
ne sais pas
qui est ce tiers c'est un prestataire
on va vous donner une réponse très
précise et vous verrez que la
crédibilité la légitimité de ce tir mais
absolument pas
ne peut pas être maître en doute mis en
doute Emmanuel va vous expliquer c'est
un prestataire qui met à disposition des
solutions qui permet à chaque grossiste
répartite d'alimenter un serveur avec
les les quantités disponibles et lui il
se contente d'agréger tout ça de
consolider tout ça et de le traduire sur
une carte pour que ce soit cartographié
et qu'on ait une vision voilà et alors
je vous dis les choses avec mes mots à
moi et en simplifiant un petit peu mais
comme vous l'a dit Laurent ça pourrait
être par molécule par classe
thérapeutique etc etc mais alors c'est
un prestataire qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec l'univers du médicament et qui
propose des solutions pour mettre en
place ce type d'observatoire pour avoir
une visibilité sur la disponibilité de
produits de services sur le territoire
c'est pas moi qui suis auditionné mais
juste confirmer que qui est pas de
confusion confirmé la qualité j'allais
dire de la chaîne logistique assurée par
les grossistes répartiteurs et je mets
pas en doute le fait que ils ont les
stocks ils livrent avec une réactivité
une activité très satisfaisante et le
rôle dans la pandémie que nous avons
connue
c'est aussi la distribution des vaccins
dans les officines de pharmacie de
France et de Navarre et à un moment
donné cette logistique a été assurée a
été donné confié à un acteur extérieur
je ne sais plus qui
c'était pour les maquettes pour les
masques oui effectivement pour les
masques ça patauger pendant deux
semaines et très vite le ministère est
revenu à ceux qui connaissaient le mieux
la logistique dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire
une semaine pendant une semaine la
distribution de masques qui était à
l'époque mise à disposition pour les
personnels de médecine de ville a été
transférée par un acteur de la
logistique
et on va dire ça il y a eu des résultats
particulièrement désastreux et donc nous
avons récupéré en moins de 24 heures
cette distribution et nous avons assuré
que la distribution puisse atteindre les
21000 pharmacies merci d'avoir pris cet
exemple madame ma mère qui illustre
l'efficacité de nos distributions alors
que je rappelle jusqu'à cette période là
nous étions dans une période où
l'ensemble de la France était confiné
chez soi et que nous nos collaborateurs
travailler et continuent à assurer la
distribution en tant que entreprise
d'importance vitale c'est bien que ce
soit dit dans ce cadre là et personne
dans le dans le milieu professionnel la
remue en cause tout ce service et
j'allais dire demain on a un problème
nucléaire les mêmes grossistes
répartiteurs livreront les comprimés
voilà donc c'est quelque chose qui ne se
voit pas mes patients ne se rendent pas
compte au quotidien de temps en temps il
voit les caisses arriver si par hasard
ils sont dans l'officine à ce moment-là
mais ça s'arrête là c'est quelque chose
qui est qui ne se voit pas qui est
invisible et qui est très efficace
pour en venir à
par rapport à votre mission parce que je
n'ai plus en tête par contre votre
mission de service public qui vous
impose un nombre de jours de stocks ça
remonte à à Caen
j'ai pu la tempête parce que on pourrait
imaginer alors je le dis mais je ne le
pense pas c'est je pousse le que parce
que comme toute entreprise que ça soit
dans le domaine de la répartition
pharmaceutique mais dans toute
entreprise on sait bien que le stock
coûte
et qu'à un moment donné on voit bien que
les entreprises travaillent à flux tendu
expliquez-nous si c'est le cas chez vous
par rapport versus il y a 20 ans ou pas
et que
l'obligation de mission de service
public et le nombre de jours de stocks
que vous devez avoir
peut au contraire n'a pas eu avoir
d'impact en terme de volume de stock
dans vos dans vos locaux qui pourraient
expliquer des ruptures plus rapides si
comme toute entreprise qui gère ses
stocks considèrent que le stock c'est de
l'argent et que on va réduire les stocks
pour pas que ça nous coûte ça
occasionnerait des ruptures est-ce que
c'est le cas j'ai donné j'ai donné la
réponse je vous facilite le travail je
vous donne la réponse dans la question
mais au moins ça sera dit réexpliquer
une fois de plus de façon à ce que ça
c'est pas une cause de rupture
évidemment faut encore avoir le
médicament qui vous arrive et puis
simplement remarque madame la Présidente
simple rappelle et puis après je vous
promets je me tais
pour autant je me souviens avoir posé
une question sur l'amoxicilline
à une personne que nous avons auditionné
qui nous avait affirmé qu'il y avait
plus de sujets elle était disponible
c'était il y a un mois c'est toujours
autant on y arrive en avoir toujours et
elle n'est pas libérée il y a pas des
flux d'amoxicilline qui arrivent comme
ça comme on veut un des un des rôles de
la commission d'enquête c'est d'avoir
des antennes un peu partout et je
confirme il n'y a pas de l'amoxicilline
dans toutes les officines en tout cas le
même jour c'est certain voilà
et je voulais juste rajouter une
question
votre observatoire
observe aussi au niveau des Outre-mer
parce que on sait que il y a
complexité particulière
non pour l'instant France et Corse
les obligations de services publics oui
oui France métropolitaine on se
metropolitaine pardon
était imprécie
les obligations de service public elle
remonte à 1962 alors cela étant elles
ont alors sur le niveau de stock à ma
connaissance elles n'ont pas évolué
depuis sur le la durée en nombre de
jours
la durée en nombre de jours c'est deux
semaines de consommation de la clientèle
habituelle
ce mot est important parce que si on
prend l'exemple du paracétamol qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure quand vous
distribuez 20% des flux
votre clientèle habituelle et vous
volumes habituels c'est 20%. donc si
tout d'un coup on vous demande d'assurer
la distribution de 100%
vous imaginez qu'il y a un petit hiatus
entre 20 et 100
donc ensuite par rapport au point que
auquel vous faisiez référence concernant
la gestion des stocks en flux tendu
versus des économies possibles en termes
de gestion trésorerie et des arbitrages
que nous pourrions faire
écouter je vais avoir une réponse assez
claire
même si nous désirions avoir sur un
certain nombre de produits en quota
faire des arbitrages en décidant d'avoir
60 jours de stock sur des produits à
quota nous ne pourrions pas le faire
puisque on a un quota qui correspond à
notre consommation d'un mois
donc nous accuser de créer donc c'est
pas ce que j'ai pas dit que vous aviez
mis une accusation mais je sais que ça
existe
oui je sais que certaines personnes
laissent à penser que
nous ferions des arbitrages économiques
pour gérer en flux tendu c'est une
ineptie
car si nous voulions par exemple prendre
des stocks de protection sur certaines
molécules parce que nous aurions eu
accès à une information privilégiée
disant que il va y avoir une rupture
d'une molécule XY ou Z dans deux mois et
que ce produit à quota nous souhaitons
protéger nos stocks et les
approvisionnements et la disponibilité
pour le marché en anticipant en faisant
des achats d'opportunités tels que
s'exprimer dans la profession nous ne
pourrions pas le faire sur des produits
à quota
et donc je rappelle ça représente 50% du
marché approvisionné par les grossistes
répartiteurs donc c'est absolument pas
un sujet d'arbitrage économique ou de
trésorerie disponibilité pour cela qui
pourrait expliquer la situation je
tenais le préciser parce qu'en tant que
chef d'entreprise vous avez raison et
madame vous êtes une chef d'entreprise
puisque vous êtes pharmacienne aussi
vous l'étiez
c'est en effet un sujet sur lequel on
pourrait se poser des questions mais ça
n'est absolument pas le cas parce que
quand bien même sur un produit à quota
en tant que chef d'entreprise je ferai
une demande de trois mois de stock je ne
serai jamais livré trois mois de stock
simplement alors moi je suis d'abord
nous arrivons à la fin de cette audition
je ne suis ni pharmacienne ni médecin
donc j'écoute avec attention ce que vous
dites mais j'ai été dans l'industrie où
on fabriquait des produits on avait nous
aussi des distributeurs on distribués
pour vous donner une idée 36000 points
on arrive à les distribuer à les mettre
à jour tous les 10 jours on avait dû
dépannage et tout donc je comprends à
peu près votre problème et c'est que
vous avez il est important quand on a
20% de stocks qui tournent à une tonne
par mois et on a 200 kg et si tout d'un
coup ce c'est une automne le se
transforme en 10 tonnes mais c'est plus
de 100 kg qu'il faut mais ces deux
tonnes alors moi la question que je me
pose est-ce que tout de suite vous avez
réactualisé les choses et vous n'avez
pas été un peu frileux que vous disiez
pour des raisons économiques ou autres
et vous avez tout de suite dit
maintenant nos stocks il faut qu'on les
monte beaucoup plus pour pouvoir faire
face à la demande et après la question
après la plus belle fille du monde ne
peut donner que ce qu'elle a donc vous
vous distribuez vous pouvez distribuer
que ce que vous avez et ce que vous nous
avez expliqué à un moment donné ça
devient de la théorie mais en Patrick
quand on a tout donné parce que la
demande a augmenté de 5 de 100% de 100%,
ou 300 %, vous avez plus rien vous
pouvez plus rien donner est-ce que
derrière à votre avis les laboratoires
qui ont fait des efforts parce que
production après il faut il faut
commencer à à mettre tout le matériel en
route quand on en a qui ne l'est pas il
faut pouvoir s'approvisionner en matière
première et puis après si on est un
simple équipe on passe au de 8 et puis
si ça supplie ne veut pas en passant
trop vite et si ça suffit pas on passe
assez vite c'est-à-dire on travaille
tous les jours dimanche compris est-ce
que à votre avis ou c'est qu'il y a eu
vraiment la faille est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui a pas joué le jeu est-ce
que ou alors c'était impossible quoi
donc je remarque je fais remarquer à
Jean-Pierre que le problème de la plus
belle fille du monde et la même chose
pour le plus bel homme du monde donc je
vous laisse répondre je
elle est fleurie mais pas très moderne
je vous laisse répondre
écoutez je pense qu'il y a tout un tas
de facteurs qui peuvent expliquer cette
situation premièrement n'oublions pas
quelque chose c'est que la situation des
ruptures de médicaments n'est pas un
sujet récent c'est un sujet qui perdure
je répète ce que je vous ai dit durant
mes propos la seule différence entre le
monde d'avant et le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça touche des
produits d'usage courant dont nos
concitoyens connaissent l'utilisation
comme l'amoxicilline le toplexil des
produits de paracétamol etc c'est là où
c'est nouveau mais le sujet de rupture
est un sujet récurrent dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique et que c'est pas quelque
chose qui vient qui vient d'arriver je
pense c'est important qu'on le considère
premier point deuxième point nous
sortons d'une période de crise très
particulière
il n'y a pas que l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui a eu des ruptures
d'approvisionnement dans les trois
dernières années
je vous rappellerai juste que même
l'automobile a eu des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de composants parce
que le covid la covid a créé des
ruptures à certains moments de
production d'un certain nombre
de composants nécessaires à l'automobile
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique on peut
considérer que c'est passé exactement la
même chose
il faut savoir aussi
que la covid a créé des perturbations
dans l'estimation de la demande de
certains produits
ce à quoi vous faisiez référence et
qu'en effet quand vous êtes industriel
le changement d'un volume de production
de certains produits est un vrai process
industriel qui se décide pas du jour au
lendemain donc le port du masque
chirurgical sur certains produits a eu
des impacts sur les volumes
commercialisés dans les années 2021 2022
le retour à la normale sur 2023 a créé
un halo une envolée d'un certain nombre
de
volumes de produits que nous n'avions
pas connu depuis deux ans il faut
peut-être penser que certains
laboratoires ont peut-être
été conservateurs dans la fabrication de
certains produits
plus des crises de matière première qui
peuvent expliquer cela plus d'autres
facteurs je veux dire une usine où vous
avez des collaborateurs qui arrêtent de
travailler parce qu'il y a des
discussions sur des négociations
annuelles sur les salaires ça peut
perturber la production donc il y a tout
un tas de facteurs donc le sujet des
ruptures c'est quelque chose que nous
sommes habitués à gérer dans le monde de
l'industrie pharmaceutique le phénomène
nouveau c'est que ça touche des
médicaments d'usage courant il faut
comprendre ce qui s'est passé sur ces
médicaments d'usage courant qui
expliquent peut-être le fait qu'on soit
devant une commission à s'expliquée sur
ce sujet là pour trouver des réponses
néanmoins je pense qu'il y a des
phénomènes structurels autour du je
pense des produits à quota qui ou je
pense que vous êtes vous avez toutes
légitimité à demander d'où viennent
l'établissement de ces côtés sur quelle
base sont fixées les volumes définis
pour cela sur peut-être d'autres
éléments perturbateurs dans la
distribution j'espère avoir été le plus
clair possible monsieur dans ma réponse
après moi autant je comprends dans
l'industrie parce que l'industrie
travaille effectivement un flux tendu et
il y a longtemps c'est depuis une
quarantaine d'années
c'était pas le cas mais vous par contre
vous ne travaillez pas en flux tendu
vous avez des stocks obligatoires et
c'est pas normal quand le temps normal
quand le temps normal oui quand il y a
pas d'augmentation de volume vous ayez
vous ayez des ruptures sur certains
produits puisque vous avez des stocks
obligatoires
très bien mais les laboratoires aussi
ont des stocks obligatoires je le
rappelle voilà merci beaucoup pour
me laisser un dernier point parce que je
crois que vous avez abordé justement
vous aviez un peu vous m'avez un peu
tendu la perche durant la durant le
l'audition et je souhaitais madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs juste
premièrement vous remercier pour cette
audition je pense qu'il était important
pour nous que nous apportions un
éclairage qui j'espère sera utile à vos
travaux
personnellement en tant que président
d'assrp je souhaiterais interpeller la
représentation nationale
sur un dernier point les propos sont
bref mais je pense qu'ils sont
importants les pénuries de médicaments
posent au fond la question générale de
l'accès aux médicaments
notre profession traverse une crise
économique depuis mars 2022 qui est
assez exceptionnel on voulait expliquer
tout à l'heure nous faisons 180 millions
de kilomètres par an
nous n'avons pas pu bénéficier des
mesures du bouclier énergétique parce
que nos entreprises sont soit d'une
taille trop grande soit la participation
des frais énergétiques dans notre modèle
économique n'était pas suffisant pour
qu'on puisse être reconnu cette
situation nécessite et j'insiste sur ce
terme l'intervention des pouvoirs
publics
s'agit d'une obligation car dans une
profession réglementée comme la nôtre
nos marges sont fixées par les pouvoirs
publics les seules jeux de manœuvre que
nous avons sont d'ordre législatif et
réglementaire à ce jour malgré de
nombreuses sollicitations nous sommes
sans nouvelles de notre autorité de
tutelle sur ce sujet depuis plus de 8
mois
pour le dire plus clairement et vous me
pardonnerez cette expression c'est pas
de son pas d'image
depuis septembre 2022 depuis janvier
2023 une commission un groupe de travail
a été créé où on devait apporter un
certain nombre de réponses à nos
entreprises la situation est grave un
certain nombre d'acteurs de la
profession prennent des mesures
drastiques
de par cette absence de réponse
il faut que nous puissions nous
retrouver si jamais nous nous retrouvons
dans quatre ans devant une nouvelle
commission d'enquête pour comprendre
pourquoi les médicaments n'arrivent plus
dans les pharmacies les gens que l'État
prennent ses responsabilités et parle
avec ceux qui assurent le service au
jour le jour pendant l'économie pendant
la pandémie et l'épidémie de covid nous
avons redécouvert l'importance de la
chaîne logistique
nos administrateurs qui sont des
grossistes répartiteurs ont démontré
leur savoir-faire et leur capacité de
mobilisation dans une période aussi
exceptionnelle
j'espère que nous n'oublierons pas à
nouveau
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie le message
est juste un point pour Madame Humbert
excusez-moi je voulais être sûr d'avoir
été clair tout à l'heure dans les 41
shortliner
identifiés et on n'a pas un qui est un
lien avec un grossiste répartiteur
adhérent à la chambre c'est après je
social et français
oh généralement oui oui oui généralement
oui oui parce que vous parlez vous
parlez des adhérents à la chambre vous
pouvez les champignons oui parce que ils
distribue en France et ce sont
généralement un établissement ou deux
mais c'est tout et il y en a pas un je
le répète qui soit qui soit ça
cela est temps sur rétradi je n'ai pas
tous les éléments de réponse on
complétera cette audition par
des éléments de de questionnaire
et donc j'allais vous proposer de voir
si vous y ajouter quelque chose je pense
que vous l'avez fait au nom de votre
profession je vous en remercie même si
je suis pas tout à fait certaine que ce
sera versé au contenu de la commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
mais le message a été reçu merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup